i had one question so you and dave
chappelle you guys are on talking terms
now right yeah and we guys were so for a
long time because what was that like you
guys
had a we were and it's okay we were
working
we the way the show went basically
the way the negotiation after
the show got popular was just not
like good did you have a were you able
were you guys negotiating together with
comedy central or
or you guys were negotiating separately
kind of separately right
um so where and that's the problem
you know that's right and i told them
before we started go you know they're
going to play divide and conquer they
have to pay you they don't have to pay
me so the only way they'll pay me
is if you make them and then they would
they
played him there it's just so many
people come
between when something's popular
it just you just get layers of uh
people that want to seem more important
and
want to seem like they're doing things
for oh of course
to protect dave or who it's not it was
dave in that case but it's
a bunch of people it can be a [ __ ]
and so
someone who actually is making the thing
they resent me you know what i mean
because like they're just
they're not writing that directing
they're not in the [ __ ] um
you mean like like an executive like not
executives like more like
lawyers agents managers they represent
you because you have to be included
because i'm part of the show
i do the show right they're not i didn't
just i don't call and
i make the show so so then that
creates a separation and then um
and then he left and it was [ __ ] like
that added to it
was that prize when he left i mean
like in retrospect not really but that's
a pretty big swing yeah yeah
okay what do you guys think yeah like
going to africa
is like that's pretty big like i didn't
see that coming although like it that's
exactly
out of proportion that's as out of
proportion as the rest of the show
right right where it's like the most
popular [ __ ] and then like
what's the leaving the show version of
the rick james sketch
going to africa right not telling anyone
all right i'll do that
uh so there's that and then
we didn't really speak we spoke a little
bit and then
since like we've been cool since like oh
seven yeah
um yeah i know you guys are i know you
guys have been for a while uh did
whenever you watched the last dance did
you think of yourself like a scottie
pippen at all yeah
of course yeah i watched i mean i said
it in three months it was like scouting
pivot
it was like it's like being on a team
with michael jordan and so
it's funny seeing pippin get mad it's
like
i want to call him be like pip there's
nothing we can do
yeah he's going there there's just
nothing you can do i'm going to play for
birmingham
for birmingham yeah you know yeah and
there's nothing and also like i gotta
get my
it they can't yeah
the audience only understands
single they don't no one's ever been on
like even when they say a dream team
one of them's better yeah they always
just like
lebron and d wade it's lebron right
capital lebron
smaller dude or lebron and anthony davis
like but the mixture makes it
of course right but and then if you're
dave but you don't want to [ __ ]
acknowledge a mixture with a [ __ ]
white person yeah
you know what i mean and i get that
[Music]
[ __ ] well you know what i mean like
yes if you'd have been black do you
think that the show would have been
picked up for another season then well
it wasn't picked up
it was picked up if i'd have been black
that's a really good question
uh
i don't it's impossible to know it would
have been a little
no but then it yeah there's a different
there would have been different tensions
if i were black there would have been
like a lot of the same ones and then a
host of other ones that i probably don't
even realize
right uh but but no of course so it's
like they don't
you watch it and you go yeah scottie
been [ __ ] great
yeah it's just not as great as yeah he
shows up he does this is not as good as
him it's like
the i that deal with that all the time
like there was a there was a
uh i went on after dave at the comedy
seller one time
and the uh the emcee was like
it's next co-creator chapelle show did
and i go and i go on i'm like
the co-grader spell show is a really
good credit
unless dave just went on
and then it's nothing
it's like yeah it's [ __ ] great oh
that's interesting unless the [ __ ]
guy
was just here it's not now you're just
like ugh
uh so i get the
it's just an insurmountable i don't i
but i i will say i'm i'm not i'm not
jealous i'm not really jealous of dave
hmm even
chris rock said that one time he's like
you're just not jealous you're just i
don't like
i'm mad i have like personal argument
[ __ ] with dave but i'm not like
i'm i should have been rick james yeah
i'm about like with
[ __ ] very different skills yeah and
uh and so i'm happy to be myself
and and to the underdog thing it is fun
to uh climb out of it
yeah it's [ __ ] sometimes i look at my
career i'm like
this is a [ __ ] miracle wow it's a
miracle that like
i was a writer for a tv show
that was really popular and now i'm a
kind of famous comedian
yeah that's [ __ ] impossible like
i wasn't a comedian and then i like
figured out how to do it and like it's
it's crazy yeah and i'm not even like
suck my d like i just mean like right
now i think about it you just get
like objective you look at your career
objectively your life objectively
you have to look at things yeah i mean
even well looking back on on chappelle
can you see like was he
just under you think like looking back
now and knowing how we see like
people get stressed and the
overwhelmingness of things do you think
yeah i think it's just
stress and i think it's not it's just
once things are not fun
it's not and also once you're talking
about that much money and people know
how much money you're making and
it's on the cover of the paper and it's
it's like
it's not it's like yeah it's it's it's
like uh
the difference i've said this to a
basketball player like difference
between a rookie contract
and a max deal rookie contract everyone
feels like
they're even if you're the best rookie
they're like man you're making five
million bucks
that's pretty [ __ ] good and then you
get your max still you're making 33
million a year
and they're like i don't know what
you're gonna do
but it [ __ ] better be good
go no go show me mr 33 million dollars
and it's just a less fun position to be
in yeah
which is the thing of having never had a
wedding
like you will will never get i don't
think anyone will ever be like
okay mr smartypants or whatever like i
don't
think that that's a thing that we may
never have to deal with
and that which is good which is a good
that's an advantage that we don't have
to
we'll have to deal with like it's not as
good as this last thing or any of that
stuff but
it'll never be like i feel like joe
somehow got around it i don't think
anyone resented him and i think it has
to do with
his looks and clothes um and habits i
don't think his habits
yeah this happens too he lifts people up
a lot you know yeah he does have to like
include people a lot
yeah um uh so that's the but i don't
but like you know me and dave argued
about it for six hours like three weeks
ago
really oh that's fun it's [ __ ]
hilarious
it's hilarious it's so interesting but
yeah what i mean what a comeback because
yeah like
to think that to go into comedy central
they won't give you a new show
and then you're like wow i mean you had
to feel well they wanted me to produce
black sketchups
that i can do till i die um they'll give
me
please yeah you got blank check for that
but i'm like i don't wanna this is not
what i that wasn't even it was a black
sketchup but it was more just a show
about dave it wasn't like and then black
something black will happen
um yeah do something somebody do
blackness
and uh so yeah it is i don't get many
opportunities
they there's just people have a bias
against me
and that i don't understand good evening
good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one ah